[Music]
it's hard to beat the glitter and glow
of glass Christmas ornaments for many
people the Christmas tree just wouldn't
be the same without them they were
invented in the 19th century by a German
glass maker who decided to improvise
because he couldn't afford to decorate
his tree with the usual nuts and candy
[Music]
there are Christmas eye candy
today's glass ornaments are a visual
treat to make some of the ornaments they
start with a sketch and make a plaster
model of it they use it to create a
two-part metal mold they take a glass
cylinder and fire its wider end so it
softens the glass maker blows into the
pipe end to stretch the supple glass
into the basic shape of a bobble
ornament other glass tubes are more
bulbous at the center and that's the
section that's fired as the glass maker
blows it into a more elongated bubble he
places that bubble in the mold and blows
extra-hard the glass expands into its
crevices and takes its shape a snowman
[Music]
he burns off one of the blowpipe ends
and then aims the torch at the snowman's
nose to pull it out a quick cooldown
could shatter this ornament so he
gradually lowers its temperature with a
less intense flame blowing and molding
glass figurines is quick work the glass
maker has just a few seconds to complete
the job before the glass becomes too
cold and stiff to shape the ornaments
now head down the line to get some shine
[Music]
this will be an inside job the glass
maker pours silvering solution into the
baubles through the stem she then dips
the bauble in warm water this activates
the silvering chemicals and shaking the
ornament accelerates this process
she swirls the silvering liquid around
to completely coat the inside of the
ornament a final dip gives this bauble a
mirror finish from the inside out
she empties the silvering solution into
another tank for recycling they also use
this technique on the figurines like the
Snowman a quick shake gives this guy an
inner beauty
[Music]
next they submerge the glass ornament in
lacquer to give it some color the mirror
finish inside shines through the lacquer
[Music]
now the snowman ornament gets an artist
touch she airbrush his white lacquer
onto the figurine for a frosty finish it
makes the snowman look more like old
frosty
[Music]
the artist paints some of the details by
hand like the trim on the hat and robe
of the Santa ornament this gives it more
visual depth
[Music]
once the paint dries she brushes glue
onto sections where she wants glitter
dust to stick the glue dries quickly so
the artist applies more when it comes to
Christmas sparkle you just can't get
enough next she makes an incision in the
stem and snaps it off
[Music]
a metal cap fits on the ornament stuff
time to pack up these fragile beauties
very carefully they put them in boxes
that cradle each one individually to
ensure they arrive safely
now these glass ornaments are ready to
go out on a limb to add Beauty to the
holidays
[Music]